ينفذ عمال وموظفوا الطرق السريعه في لندن
وجنوب شرقي بريطانيا اضرابا عن العمل
يستمر اربعه ايام ياتي ذلك في اطار موجه
متصاعده من الاضرابات في قطاعات متعددات
تطالب برفع الرواتب وتحسين ظروف العمل
تفاصيل جديده يطلعنا عليها
اسد الله الصاوي تفضل اسد الله
[موسيقى]
الذي تتجمع فيه الاسر البريطانيه في
العامه سيامه في يوم عيد الميلاد على
العشاء عيد الميلاد هذا العام يفسد هذا
تجمع كثره الاضرابات
يعني العاملين في الطرق السريعه اليوم كما
استفتي كان لدينا قبل ايام اضراب العاملين
في مرفق الاسعاف والعاملين في طواقم
التمريض لدينا غدا همم ضباط الجوازات في
اهم مطارات بريطانيا واوروبا
وجاتو ومطارات اخرى كثيره وايضا في كثير
من الموانئ البريطانيه والدينا اضراب
لعمال البريد في عموم بريطانيا هذه الخدمه
من الخدمات المهمه في هذا الوقت من العام
هذه هي الفتره التي ترسل فيها بطاقات
الكريسماس واعياد الميلاد الى الاهل
والاصدقاء والاقارب لن يصل اي من هذه
البطاقات او كثير منها سيتاخر حتى
والهدايا كده جديد هذا العام فكره
الاضرابات والهدايا كذلك بالتاكيد كل هذا
سيتاخر وابتلى عيد الميلاد والاحتفالات
هذا العام تختلف بمذاق مختلف ربما اكثر
همم هناك همم توعد باضطرابات اخرى خلال
اسبوع لدينا اضراب مجددا لتوقم الاسعاف
لدينا اضراب ل همم طواقم
عفوا المدرسين في اسكتلندا وفي مناطق اخرى
ولا لدينا همم اضرابات للعاملين في الطرق
ايضا في اوائل العام وبعد غد يبدا
العاملون في السكك الحديديه مرفقه السكك
الحديديه اضرابا عاما يستمر عده ايام هذه
المرفق بالتحديد هو ال- يعني الملا-
الرئيسيه للاسر التي لا تسافر بالسياره
التي تسافر وسيله النقل الابرز في
بريطانيا بسكاكا الحديديه كلها هؤلاء سيء
يعني سيضربون وفي وقت واحد بالتوا وحتى
ولو بالتتاليف الفترات بينهم قريبه للغايه
هذا بالتاكيد يؤثر على بريطانيا وهذا ايضا
يؤثر على حركه همم التجاره التي تنشط عاده
في هذه الفتره سيامه لشراء الهدايا وعبر
الانترنت بالفعل اسد الله اي شخص عاش في
بريطانيا يدرك اهميه السكك الحديديه خصوصا
في التنقل شكرا جزيلا فما بالك في هذا
الوقت من العام شكرا جزيلا لك اسعد الله